so knowing that it's a chipping away
it's not sort of an instant rise
um
how do you respond to friends colleagues
whomever
who say hey i know you know so and so
can you get my work to that person
uh it's it's very interesting um
when
uh killing winston jones was going
uh
there were some write-ups and variety
and and on hollywood reporter and
deadline and and some of my friends who
had seen those
started approaching me pretty often and
you know asking me how did you get it
done how did it happen can you help me
out i mean even people who are outside
of the industry
who maybe i grew up with or you know
from my hometown
just heard that i'd i'd gotten a little
bit of success and all of a sudden you
know they hadn't written a day in their
lives i don't even know if they'd read
screenplays before or read novels but
they were banging on my door and saying
they wanted to be screenwriters you know
because if if i could do it you know
then why couldn't they do it um so i
would i but i would never discourage
anyone from pursuing writing you know as
i mentioned before it's it's a very
difficult art form where um
where there are challenges on a daily
basis and storytelling
but um
you know
usually when someone comes to me and
they have a script or they want to help
me get it to someone else or
if they uh uh you know want me to
they want to pitch me an idea i will
always be open to listening to that idea
uh
that being said
that idea has to be something that i'm
interested in so if they want me to get
a script to someone i will of course
read that script and then make that
ultimate decision if it's something that
i love
sure i'll take it to anybody whoever
wherever i think it works or wherever
they want it to go if i have connections
i would love to help them out if it's
something that i
think needs work or
you know need some revisions or
a different you know
a different approach i will let them
know that as well so i think you know a
prime example is a friend of mine who is
a transplant surgeon here in los angeles
contacted me last january because he'd
heard the killing winston jones was in
production
and he called me and said
i
want to congratulate you on the film and
i'd love to sit down with you
and
talk to you about writing
so when usually when i get that from
someone i know it means one of two
things especially if they're outside of
the industry it either means
they
think that their life is very
interesting and they should they think
they deserve a reality tv show you know
or something or it's because they want
to pitch me an idea and usually it's the
latter so
i had a feeling that he was going to try
to pitch me an idea which i'm always
open to but for some reason over the
course of several weeks and months i
kept getting other meetings and i had to
push this lunch
finally we sat down maybe four or five
months later and he started pitching me
an idea
and it was amazing it was
probably the best pitch i've ever heard
if not the best one of the top five
and it was from someone who was like i
said a transplant surgeon outside of of
the industry and i knew from that moment
that was something that i wanted to work
on and the moment i left that meeting i
took it to joel david moore
i pitched him we were talking about
different projects but i pitched him
this idea he loved it
uh he had a meeting later that day with
icm talking about different projects
pitched them they loved it
and that evening someone from icm sat
down with the development exec at amc
and off the record pitched them and they
said it's fantastic show us something
when you have it so within a 24-hour
period
it went up the chain to a network you
know to amc
um
and that's unheard of that that process
would take weeks or months if you have a
great concept
so i think given the right project if
anyone brings me anything and i like it
and i believe in it and i think it has
legs i will definitely help you and
if i can and i'll take it to the you
know the people that i that i have
connections with um
but you know if it's a project and
unfortunately it's just the way that it
is
99.9 percent of the time
uh scripts or concepts or projects need
a lot of work and if they're willing to
put the work in i'll give them my
thoughts thought my thoughts my my notes
my ideas and
and if they get it to a place where i
think it's bulletproof and great i'll
take it out but it's a process and it's
a long process and that's what i hope
that my friends do for me you know i
know it's it's not easy if if i take a
project to joel or or to john or to
richard or someone you know
they have to like it in order to take it
to their connections and their people i
don't expect them to just take it to
people because they know me and we're
friends you know it has to be because
it's a good piece of material and and
that
you know i think that that's respectful
you